non madame la présidente viennent pas
recrutement de
refléter l'esprit de nos débats et des
conclusions et si d'aucuns pensaient que
la guerre dans nos contrées faisait
partie de l'histoire depuis quinze jours
le choix de la russie du président
poutine a été de faire revenir la guerre
en europe
face à celle ci est à cette violence
inouïe déployés par la russie contre
l'ukraine et son peuple et un tournant
tragique pour notre histoire nous avons
tous une croix pleinement conscience que
c'est aussi un tournant pour nos
sociétés nos peuples et notre projet
européen
nous y avons répondu depuis quinze jours
madame la présidente monsieur le
président viennent de le dire avec unité
rapidité et esprit de responsabilité
les choix ont été faits vite
à 27 avec nos institutions et coordonnée
avec l'ensemble de nos partenaires dans
le cadre de l'otan comme du g16 et avec
un travail diplomatique qui a permis
d'isoler la russie en particulier à
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
encore récemment
depuis deux semaines les ukrainiennes et
les ukrainiens se battent avec courage
pour défendre leur liberté la démocratie
leur souveraineté l'intégrité de leur
territoire
les européens ont un positionnement
clair condamnation unanime et cernes de
l'agression russe
condamnation dans toutes les enceintes
internationales mais nous en avons tiré
toutes les conséquences avec particulier
les résolutions portées la victoire en
assemblée générale nous avons décidé un
soutien inédit à l'ukraine en livrant
ensemble des équipements du matériel
humanitaire mais aussi des armes et nous
avons proposé aujourd'hui que
la facilité européenne de paix soit
complétée de 500 millions d'euros
ce qui permet d'aller plus loin encore
dans cette perspective et des pays qui
jusqu'àlors
avait une tradition de neutralité autour
de la table je pense à la suède ont
décidé pour la première fois depuis tant
de décennies de participer à ce soutien
concret à l'ukraine soutien économique
aussi que nous allons poursuivre soutien
humanitaire en accueillant en effet plus
de deux millions de réfugiés madame la
présidente a rappelé l'importance de
cette solidarité et je veux ici rendre
hommage au peuple polonais slovaques
roumains hongrois pour ce qui est notre
union mais aussi moldave pour leur élan
de solidarité d'humanité j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire la france prendra
sa part et je souhaite que nous
puissions avoir les mécanismes de
solidarité qu'ils puissent pleinement
s'activer dans ce cette approche
des premiers jours nous avons aussi
déployé un dispositif de sanction massif
inédit rapide
2e 4e 6e jour de conflit ont été marqués
par des décisions européennes de
sanction inédite
rapidité caractère massif et nous sommes
prêts à adopter d'autres sanctions
toutes les options sont sur la table et
l'objectif aussi nos discussions et de
pouvoir nous préparer à ces sanctions si
elles étaient de nature à pouvoir
arrêter
l'agression et à nous préparer aussi à
toutes les conséquences dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent notre
premier objectif
demeure bien sûr un retour rapide à la
paix en commençant par un cessez le feu
suivi d'un retrait rapide des troupes
russes et c'est pourquoi nous maintenons
la pression sur la russie et que nous
maintenons aussi un dialogue exigeant
particulier en lien avec le chancelier
allemand
se soutient cette solidarité à l'ukraine
c'est elle aussi qui nous arrive hier
beaucoup occupée nous soutenons
aujourd'hui l'ukraine et nous la
soutiendrons aussi longtemps que la
guerre durera et nous serons là pour
reconstruire ce que l'agression brutale
et injustifiée de la russie a détruit
et pour panser rebâtir et l'aider à se
relever dans la durée le message que
nous avons ainsi adressé aux ukrainiens
et que le chemin vers notre europe leur
est ouvert leur combat pour la liberté
et la démocratie pour les valeurs qui
nous rassemblent à démontrer que
l'ukraine appartient bien à notre
famille européenne nous avons aussi
souhaité que les candidatures qui avait
été soumise par la moldavie et la
géorgie puissent être examinés comme
neutre et elle prévoit par la commission
européenne afin que l'acceptabilité de
leur candidature et la potentielle
ouverture puisse se faire en fonction de
notre de notre été
la déclaration de versailles au fond
l'agenda de versailles que nous avons
discuté aujourd'hui
vient d'acter du fait que la
souveraineté européenne si certains
pouvaient il y a quelques années il voir
un slogan peut-être pour d'aucuns une
fantaisie française
chacun comprend aujourd'hui que c'est un
impératif
et que cette souveraineté cette
autonomie stratégique
nous en avons vécu l'importance dé la
pandémie
quand il s'est agi l'obtenir c'est un
équipement de santé certains matériels
nous n'avons vécu quand il s'est agi de
pouvoir produire et disposer de 25 pour
nous mêmes et les pays que nous voulions
aider nous l'avons vécu en sortie de
crise au moment de la relance comme nous
nous sommes aperçus que disposer de semi
conducteurs quand nous en avions délégué
la production à l'autre bout du monde
était compliquée pour faire repartir la
production automobile ou d'autres et
nous le voyons pleinement avec cette
crise
mesurons combien
notre alimentation notre énergie notre
défense sont aussi des sujets de
souveraineté où nous pouvons coopérer où
nous voulons être une puissance ouverte
au monde mais où nous voulons choisir
nos partenaires et ne pas dépendre d'eux
et ce à la souveraineté ça n'est pas le
protectionnisme ça n'est pas se refermer
c'est d'avoir la possibilité de rester
ouverts sans être dépendant et donc
l'agenda de versailles ainsi scandé les
prochains mois de travail pour avancer
dans cette direction
en matière de défense nous souhaitons
pouvoir définir les investissements dont
nous avons besoin plusieurs d'entre nous
sommes d'ores et déjà 2 % de votre
produit national brut investi en matière
de défense d'autres ont des efforts à
faire mais nous voulons le faire de
manière coordonnée identifier les
besoins qui sont les nôtres sur le plan
budgétaire
identifier les capacités qui sont à
bâtir identifie aussi nos besoins sur
les confessions où les conflits qualité
nous werk nouvelle qu'il s'agisse du
spatial du cyber du maritime et
identifier ce qui aussi a du sens pour
construire des filières industrielles
européennes avoir une europe qui dépense
plus en matière de défense si c'est pour
importer davantage de matériel fait
ailleurs n'aurait pas grand sens en
terme de souveraineté il nous faut
continuer d'avoir certains partenariats
mais il nous faut aussi décidé de
consolider pâtir décideurs industriels
de défense avec moins de standards mais
qui correspondent à un marché pleinement
intégrée à 7 à cet effet nous avons pris
plusieurs décisions d'ores et déjà la
france comme vous le savez depuis 2017 a
fait des choix budgétaires
massifs pour atteindre dès l'année
dernière c'est 2% l'investissement et
pour relancer beaucoup de ces filières
et de ses capacités l'allemagne a décidé
il y a un peu plus de dix jours à son
tour de porter des investissements
historiques pour son pays le danemark a
fait aussi un choix historique celui de
soumettre à son peuple dans quelques
mois la possibilité de revenir dans le
projet européen de sécurité et de
défense vous le voyez partout sur notre
continent des choix historiques sont en
train d'être pris qui marque un tournant
majeur il nous faut l'organiser au
niveau européen pour bâtir cette
capacité commune en matière de défense
c'est l'objet du mandat qui a été confié
à la commission pour que d'ici au mois
de mai nous puissions dans le cadre de
ce qui sera sans doute un conseil
extraordinaire et qui précédera le
sommet de l'otan du mois de juin de
bâtir une stratégie européenne
pleinement établis en matière
d'investissement de renforcement nos
industries de capacité ensuite il ya le
sujet de l'énergie
nous avons d'ores et déjà à travers la
stratégie climatique qui est la nôtre au
fond commencer à bâtir un chemin
d'indépendance
sortir des énergies fossiles c'est
devenir indépendant néanmoins nous
savions que sur cette route pour
beaucoup d'entre nous la sortie du
charbon en particulier passer par le gaz
un gaz que nous importons et que nous
importons encore de russie la situation
que nous vivons aujourd'hui
celle que nous vivrons immanquablement
demain doit nous conduire à réévaluer
cette stratégie en étant encore plus
ambitieux sur le plan climatique
à cet effet nous aurons un rendez vous
dès la fin du mois de mars nous
regarderons de manière très concrète
comment d'abord accompagné nos peuples
sur la question des prix c'est le mandat
qu'il a aussi confié à la commission des
options concrètes sur les prix des
options concrètes sur le remplissage ce
sont des sujets très techniques mais de
quoi s'agit-il au fond de permettre de
garantir des mécanismes qui évite d'être
soumis aux aléas du marché parfois aux
spéculations du marché lié à ce contexte
de crise beaucoup d'entre nous avons
fait des choix pour protéger d'ores et
déjà nos compatriotes nos entreprises
nous devons harmoniser ses choix au
niveau européen et nous doter
d'instruments nouveaux dans les quinze
jours qui viennent pour mieux résister
aux chocs de prix lié à ce contexte
géopolitique les prix montaient déjà
avant la guerre et ils continuent de
monter du fait de 16
ensuite nous devons aussi nous préparer
à d'éventuelles sanctions qui viendront
et nous nous devons nous préparer à nous
désensibiliser de cette dépendance à la
russie c'est l'objet du mandat qui est
donné pour le mois de mai à la
commission avec ce plan d' dont le
président et madame la présidente
rappelait l'importance plan pour la
sortie de la dépendance fossiles à
l'égard de la russie c'est à dire
comment sortir d'ici à 2027 de notre
dépendance au gaz au pétrole et au
charbon russe
c'est un plan qui suppose des
investissements nouveaux des équipements
nouveaux une stratégie qui va renforcer
les choix que nous avons faits en
matière en particulier
de renouvelables et de nucléaire
vous le voyez là aussi mars et mai
seront structurées par un agenda très
fort sur le plan énergétique enfin nous
avons les autres sujets sur lesquels
nous devons bâtir également notre
indépendance et notre souveraineté
la stratégie alimentaire dans un
contexte où qu'il s'agisse du blé du
maïs
des céréales largement parlé l'ukraine
et la russie sont deux marchés très
importants notre europe est d'ores et
déjà déstabilisé par la guerre à cet
égard elle le sera encore plus dans 12
18 mois en raison de ce qui ne peut être
plantés en ce moment même en ukraine et
l'europe mais avec l l'afrique seront
très profondément déstabilisé sur le
plan alimentaire il nous faut donc là
aussi nous préparer et réévaluer nos
stratégies de production pour d'abord
défendre notre souveraineté alimentaire
et notre souveraineté protéinique en
européen mais pouvoir aussi définir et
réévaluer une stratégie à l'égard de
l'afrique sans quoi plusieurs pays en
afrique seront touchés dans la période
de 12 à 18 mois par des famines en
raison précisément de la guerre
souveraineté en matière en ce qui
concerne aussi d'autres matières
premières en ce qui concerne des
matériaux rares souveraineté évidemment
je l'évoqué en matière de semi
conducteurs de santé je ne veux pas ici
faire toute la liste mais nous avons à
travers cet agenda
scandaient les prochains mois pour des
décisions très concrètes
d'investissement qui vont permettre de
bâtir cette europe plus indépendante et
plus souveraine ceci veut dire que nous
aurons à encourager des investissements
privés c'est tout l'objet de la
taxonomie en matière d'énergie c'est
l'objet aussi d'un travail que nous
devons accélérer pour parachever l'union
des capitaux en europe et 1 et
l'approfondissement du marché unique
dans les différents secteurs
deuxième point il nous faut avoir une
politique monétaire adaptée nous ne
sommes pas revenus à des temps normaux
de manière évidente et la banque
centrale européenne devra poursuivre le
travail suite à ces annonces d'hier mais
il est très clair que nous rentrons dans
une zone de très fortes tensions dues
aussi au contexte géopolitique
troisième levier nous aurons des
stratégies nationales d'investissement
public pour nous protéger des
conséquences de la guerre pour financer
notre solidarité et notre résistance à
ses conséquences mais financé aussi ses
stratégies de souveraineté et quatrième
point il nous faudra aussi en européens
financés comme nous avons su le faire
pendant la pandémie ces grandes
stratégies que je viens d'évoquer et le
faire parce qu'on parle
d'investissements pour notre futur que
nous parlons d'investissement conjoint
que nous avons un intérêt à coordonner
ses investissements et que nous avons
aussi intérêt à financer cela en
l'européen pour éviter toute
fragmentation du marché financier et des
dettes souveraines européennes
c'est la stratégie que nous avons
commencé ici à travailler qui va nous
occuper dans les prochains mois mais là
aussi il nous faudra faire preuve
d'unité de rapidité et d'esprit de
responsabilité
les ukrainiennes et les ukrainiens nous
donne un exemple
unique celui du courage
nous ne faisons pas la guerre
nous européens aujourd'hui à la russie
mais nous soutenons comme je le disais
l'ukraine nous sanctionnons la russie
mais nous devons aussi faire notre part
et avoir le courage de prendre les
décisions historiques
d'assumer le fait que défendre la
démocratie et nos valeurs un coup que
faire ses choix d'indépendance a un coût
et suppose de revenir sur parfois des
dogmes que nous avions depuis de
nombreuses années des organisations des
habitudes qui étaient les nôtres et je
crois pouvoir dire que les discussions
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui ont consacré
la prise de conscience et la volonté des
européennes et des européens ici à
versailles d'avancer dans cette
direction et je finirai sur ces mots
jeantet meyer nos travaux en remerciant
certains de mes collègues et je le dis à
madame la présidente de la commission
qu'à versailles qui est un immense lieu
d'histoire que les françaises et les
français aiment plus que tout et qui
notre fierté à l'égard du reste du monde
à othis aussi parfois été un lieu
qui a résonné avec des défaites
diplomatique
c'est aussi le lieu
nous avons perdu la paix à la fin de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
et après avoir gagné la guerre nous
avons perdu la paix parce que nous avons
à ce moment-là acté la volonté
d'humilier et de diviser l'europe
et je suis très fier que durant ces deux
jours
malgré les difficultés la gravité la
lourdeur parfois l'émotion extrême qu'il
y avait autour de la table
nous avons tous ensemble de manière
unanime
acté que le seul moyen de préserver la
paix sur notre continent était notre
unité et c'était le courage de cette
unité
et c'est le plus important à mes yeux je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le président je tiens à
vous informer que on vient de publier
notre déclaration de versailles dont les
24 langues de l'union européenne
vous êtes la première qui va poser une
question ok bonjour angélique pana
d'actions internationales donc de radio
france vous avez eu deux jours de sommet
c'est la première fois que vous voyez
aussi longtemps depuis depuis cette
guerre vous parler d'europe plus
puissante face à moscou nous parler
d'agenda vous nous parlez de 2027 vous
nous parler d'éventuels autres sur
sanction mais sur le terrain on a vu
cette maternité bombardé kiev est
encerclé vous avez certes réagi vite et
fort on l'a vu aujourd'hui ça ne suffit
pas et quand même le sentiment qui sort
de ce sommet c'est que vous n'avez plus
ni vraiment d'outils ni d'unanimité pour
une mesure forte et rapide aujourd'hui
j'insiste sur aujourd'hui de nature à
faire plier poutine alors est ce que
vous êtes quand même aujourd'hui un
puissant
soyons clairs
il y à une guerre sur le terrain et nous
ne sommes pas en guerre ce que vous
pointez est vrai mais la réalité
politique le choix souverain qui est le
nôtre est aussi celui là
et donc vous avez parfaitement raison de
dire que nous n'avons pas une réponse
sur un théâtre de guerre qui a été
déclenché par l'agression de la russie
parce que nous ne sommes pas en guerre
sur le terrain
est-ce que nous excluons des sanctions
supplémentaires en aucun cas la
déclaration du g7 qui sortira dans
quelques heures va d'ailleurs acté une
perspective de sanctions supplémentaires
soit une première vague me tais et en
fonction de l'évolution des événements
sur le terrain nous n'excluons rien et
nous l'avons rappelé et je peux vous
dire ici j'ai la certitude si les choses
continuent et sur le plan militaire dans
la droite ligne de ce que vous venez de
décrire que nous prendrons des sanctions
nouvelles y compris des sanctions
massives mais aujourd'hui
les européens interviennent de trois
manières
les sanctions contre la russie
et nous en prendrons d'autres et si
les circonstances l'exigent l'exigent
nous les prendrons et jusqu'au bout le
soutien l'ukraine nous le poursuivons et
nous le poursuivrons là aussi et
l'action diplomatique pour isoler la
russie aux nations unies et pour essayer
de convaincre
le président poutine de revenir à la
table des négociations de manière
sincère avec l'ukraine et le président
ukrainien pour trouver un accord
voilà le cadre dans lequel nous agissons
cela étant nous condamnons avec la plus
grande fermeté et je partage votre
émotion quand nous voyons les scènes à
kharkiv
voix marioupol
inacceptable et odieuses que nous avons
vu mais aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas
nous européens sur le sol ukrainien en
guerre
isync
et de pinto est tout à fait atroce
odieux et je crois qu'il doit y avoir
une enquête pour crimes de guerre c'est
quelque chose qui doit être prise en
compte de manière sobre néanmoins
j'appuie le fait que nous en sommes au
15e jour de cette guerre horrible et
comme l'a dit le président
dès le deuxième jour de le quatrième
jour dès le 6e jour
à chaque étape nous avions un bouquet de
sanctions une semaine plus tard
aujourd'hui on voit que le rouble est en
chute libre il a perdu plus de 50% par
rapport à l'euro on voit que les taux
d'intérêt explosent on peut s'y mouvoir
une hausse
vertigineuse des taux les agences de
cotation
ne considère plus les obligations russes
que comme des obligations qui ne valent
plus rien
autant d'éléments qui montrent
l'incidence importance de nos sanctions
le quatrième bouquet va être une réalité
et nous avons nos propres moyens de
répondre à ces agressions atroce dont se
rend coupable
poutine et nous déterminerons une
réponse appropriée
l'approché
de bfm tv a gagné